No. Are you sure? Yes, I'm sure. So, if
I killed if I killed your kids and I
said I'm defending myself, would you
accept that? Yes. What?
[Music]
We want to establish an amazing masid
for the sake of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
in the country of Norway. Click on the
link and donate now for the sake of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala. I have given
myself the duty to hunt Hamas member in
central London and I know people that
know this member very closely. So we're
going to be showing a picture of this
Hamas member which you see on the screen
right now with my left or right. Yes. In
Balaclava. Yes. Wearing the whole Hamas
costume. But we're going to show the
real identity and see if these parents
know where this Hamas member is and
we're going to track them down. No. No.
No. Are you sure? Yes, I'm sure. So, do
you know this person? Uh, no, but I see
Palestina flag. Okay, one second. Look
at the eyes. Do you know her? No. Hi.
They're very danger. Hamas member. What?
Yeah. Hamas. Hamas. Can you say mama?
No, I can't say mama. Can you say papa?
I can say daddy though. You heard of
her? Oh, I've seen her. She's scary.
[Music]
Hi.
Hello. Can you say
mama? Mama. Does it ring a bell? No. No.
Okay. Is it like Gomez or someone? No.
Does that ring a bell? Can you say mama?
Have you ever Miss Rachel? Who? Miss
Rachel. Oh, you know Miss Rachel? Yeah.
Hi. Hello. Hello. Can you say mama? Do
you know who she is? Something of a kids
channel. Kids channel. Okay.
Hi.
Hello. Can you say mama?
Mama. Do you know Do you know this
person? Do you know this person? You
don't know this person? Uh because I I
Instagram, not Tik Tok. Have you heard
of her? Oh, I've seen her. She's scary.
Oh,
and she's a teacher, isn't she? Her name
is Miss Rachel. Yeah. Okay. So,
basically, she put a post out saying,
"Do you not kill innocent Palestinian
children?" Now, they're attacking and
putting an investigation saying that she
works with Hamas just because she
said person. No, no, that's her. We just
put a shopped. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Photoshop. My friend D. So, big up to my
friend. Okay. So, the point is this,
sister. Isn't Do you believe innocent
children should be killed? No. Okay.
Does that make you hammers? No. Yeah. So
the point is this. Just because she put
a post up saying Palestinian children
should not be killed or don't dehumanize
them, they are now doing an
investigation saying that she's linked
she has links to Hamas. That's stupid.
Stupid is not the word. There's another
word, but I will not say on camera.
Thank you for your reaction. That was
it. Any words you would say to the
stupid Zionist regime? Oh, I don't know.
People suck. They do. They need to sort
their lives out and just figure it all
out. You heard you heard what she said.
Sort it out right now. Okay. Thank you
very much. Okay. Thank you for your
time. Bye-bye. Hamas now. They're saying
she's a terrorist. Like they're saying
she's Yeah. So, do you think that's
correct? Like, do you believe kids
should be killed? No, of course not.
Does that mean you're Hamas? Does that
make you a terrorist? Uh, if you kill
children, you're a terrorist. Yes. If
you if No, if if you say don't kill
children, does that make you a
terrorist? No, of course not. But if you
kill innocent people and also just you
know, I got to say something honest. I'm
for Israel because I'm Christian and I
believe it's uh it's God's uh country
God's country. as people so yeah you can
see it I act like this because I just
but I believe we don't we don't need bar
in the world but do you do you do you do
you condone or condemn the killing of
the Palestinian children Hamas also
kills people also because Israel people
okay okay but what I'm saying is that
the 50,000 innocent children and kids
have been killed you still support it do
you still support Israel what they do
because Isra Hamas started the war when
when did when did Hamas start the war so
what what happened before 7 in October
uh 2003 happened like so do you do you
believe she's I don't believe she's ham
but I believe Hamas is wrong and this
group I don't think Palestinian is wrong
but does it make you a terrorist if you
say don't kill kids that make you a
terrorist okay that's what we're saying
so so do you would the question have a
little
bit but I believe Israel is in the good
I believe they're in the good by killing
50,000 kids okay but what about Israel
if it was 50,000 innocent men Israel is
defending Israel is defending their
country and I'm I think we're So if I
killed if I killed your kids and I said
I'm defending myself, would you accept
that? Yes.
So you would accept me killing your
children off the fence if you're
defending yourself? Yes, of course.
Because Israel always has anti. So if I
come and take your house from you, kick
you out from your house and kill your
children. Yes. But Hamas is exact
exactly the same. No. How is when was
when was Israel created? Uh in after the
Second World War. But I believe because
I'm a Christian, it was way before. So
because you're because you're a
Christian, you support people killing
kids just because you support it's a
God's habit. We actually look at the
Hamas. Hamas also did it. No, no, but
the Hamas didn't start. Not 7th October,
but before that. No, it didn't. Why
October? Sure. But I think we can't
agree with this one because we have
different opinions and I really But it
didn't start from 7th October. And
you're a Christian. You follow Candace
Owens. A real Christian doesn't support
this. I I am a Christian. I support my
country. A true Christian shouldn't.
I'm Wow. I'm I'm unbelievable. She calls
Miss Rachel, she's not a terrorist for
saying that, but then at the same time
she calls her support Israel and she's
going Israeli symbol. You can't make
this stuff up yet. Y recently she put a
post out saying stop killing Palestinian
kids. Yeah. Now she's under
investigation. They're calling her being
funed by Hamas. So that's Yeah, exactly.
So So they're basically saying that
she's pro Hamas. It goes from nursery
rhymes to Hamas lines. Wow. And I was
like, cuz And literally all she said
was, "Stop killing kids." The only thing
she said, "Do you believe kids should
not be killed?" Absolutely. Okay. You're
a hamster. Okay, we're going to arrest
you. We're going to call the police now.
Can Yes. It's It's unbelievable. I mean,
the And you know what it is? It's like
the reason I'm doing this is also to
raise awareness about anti-semitism.
Real anti-semitism because there's
Islamophobia. And if someone out there
like Muslim community were doing absurd
stuff like that, I would be like,
"You're belittling Islamophobia cuz
there's real Islamophobia." Yeah. So to
me it was
alsist themselves because you are you're
making it worse for the Jewish people.
And by the way, most of them are
atheists. Yeah, I completely agree. I
don't know a like a lot about the
situation, but it's like I look at it
from the point of view of like it's not
anti-semitism to stand up for the rights
of innocent people. right now at all.
Yeah. And anyone, it doesn't matter.
Like it's not a religious issue. It's
like an like it's an injustice. Like
we're going to say that it's genocide in
a year's time. But what makes me so sad
is they're not going to stop till it's
done. Exactly. That's the thing. And
that's the reason why sometimes we ask,
okay, how could people in Nazi Germany
watch what happen? But this is Nazi
Germany now. Like as in it's like we're
looking at this now and everyone's just
like, don't say anything about it.
Exactly. I mean, thank you very much.
That was it. I really appreciate it. I
wish that I could actually do more. I
think it's really cool that you're doing
I think your reaction did enough. That's
what he's looking for. Your reaction
before? No. So, this is Miss Rachel.
Miss Rachel? Yeah. Yeah. So, she does
little videos for kids. She was labeled
a um anti-semite and she's been accused
of being funded by Hamas because she
said don't kill Palestinian children. Do
you believe Palestinian children should
be killed? No. Does that make you Hamas?
What? That's that's to their argument.
So, they're saying that because she said
Palestinian children should not be
killed. Yeah. They've made a her
connected to Hamas. They've made her
connected to but that is a crazy story.
That that is a crazy story and that's
exactly and this is actually real.
They're actually doing an investigation
on her because she said do not kill
Palestinian children. They're like okay
she's got links to Hamas. Okay this
person this the picture.
I This is Miss Rachel. She does YouTube
videos for babies for kids.
Well basically she put a post out saying
Palestinian children should not be
killed. So they think now she's a Hamas
terrorist. Does that make you a Hamas
terrorist if you say that? Not at all.
Are you sure? Do you believe children
should be killed? No. You're Hamas.
We're going to we're going to arrest you
now. I mean, how how would you actually
treat it like that?
What would you say? Well, don't you
think that is actually more anti-semitic
by belittling the anti anti-semitism by
making it seem as if stupid things like
this just because she said do not kill
innocent Palestinian children, now
there's an investigation on her and she
should be warned against. I agree with
what you're saying. Exactly. I
appreciate it, man. Thank you. That was
it. Okay. So this is Miss Rachel. This
is her undercover.
Okay. So basically she put a post out
saying um Palestinian children should
not be killed and now they are attacking
her saying that she is anti-Semitic. Do
you believe innocent children should be
killed? No. Does that make you a
Hamas? Exactly. Say no more in it. Miss
Rachel is She's not Hamas, is she? No.
Thank you very much. High five. You are
a real You're the champion. And you're
the champion. Come on. Okay, Miss
Rachel. Yes, Miss Rachel. There you go.
Thank you very much. Look after mommy.
Yeah. Yeah. She said that Palestinian
children Yeah. should not be killed.
Okay. And the Zionist, Israelis, they
said she is Hamas. Yeah. Is she Hamas?
Okay. All right. Do you do you think
she's Hamas? Because she said stop
killing children. No.
Okay. So, do you guys believe children
should be killed?
Nothing that means you are you are you
are Hamas. No you're a terrorist. No no
no that's say that was the point of my
video to show just because someone says
kids shouldn't be killed it doesn't mean
they are Hamas. Some may think this
video is to raise awareness against
Islamophobia. It's actually not. It's to
the contrary sisters. It's about raising
awareness about anti anti-semitism. The
biggest anti-semmites are Zionists,
godless, moralists individuals who kill
innocent men, women, and children who do
not even believe in God themselves and
use it under the pretense of Judaism or
whatever it is for that matter. Subhan
Allah. So this video was to highlight
how stupid, illogical, idiotic these
people are that so much so they are
trying to cancel Miss Rachel, tie links
with her by saying, you know, she went
from to the rhymes to Hamas lines for
that matter. It's unbelievable. So much
so that they now even trying to pass
legislation that anyone in the past two
years in America that criticized the
United States of Israel will get their
citizenship lost. And you saw with us
speaking to people how stupid and
idiotic they found this. And the reason
why I done a social experiment is just
to show people the true reality. We want
to thank Zionist because without you
guys and your stupidity, idiotic um
behavior, we wouldn't be able to do
this. The whole world would have not be
seeing your whole reality. This is the
beginning and the end of Zionism. Yes.
And we hope that Jews around the world
are not affected by their hate because
Jews are not every every Zionist might
be a Jew, but not every Jew is a
Zionist. And let's make that distinction
clear. And this video was to raise
awareness to anti-semitism for innocent
Jews around the world who may be
attacked. So brothers and sisters, hope
you enjoyed this. Please share
inshallah. And to Miss Rachel, thank you
for speaking up against the genocide
that is taking place. Asalam alaikum.
Islam is establishing a masjid and a
community center. If you donate to build
this masjid, Allah will inshallah build
a house for you in Jenna with bricks of
gold and silver. Every person who prays
in this masjid, every child that
memorizes the Quran, you will inshallah
share in that reward. Donate now guys
and do not delay.
[Music]